who's the current president  well  i don't believe that uh the current  president is a legitimate president and  we'll leave it at that is joe biden  currently the president even if you  think he's illegitimate is he the  president  i don't believe he is i don't believe  that is the current legitimate president  and who is the current legitimate  president  um  i don't i don't believe we have a  current legitimate president wow so in a  sense there's no president of the u.s  right now  i guess that's your interpretation of  what i said but okay  will you tell me i mean is there a  president right now i guess  um  well i i'd rather not answer that how's  that because i kind of feel like you're  leading down an area of controversy  um that we don't have to go  okay interesting